tell me the law that i have broken by
being here today
tell me what law i have broken you
cannot tell me
any law that i've broken the law he's
broken is that protesters can't meet in
groups of more than two
under current emergency corona virus
legislation and he was in a group of
three protesters outside king's cross
station
ironically now swamped by many more
police and photographers
as he was taken away
but what if groups of three suddenly
become three thousand
a mile or so down the road a much larger
group had gathered at marble arch where
there were fewer officers available to
break things up
they marched down oxford street which on
any other year would be bustling with
christmas
shoppers this group of people clearly
don't believe in the science they don't
believe in the lockdown
and they don't consider it necessary to
have social distances
the question now how would the police
disrupt this much larger group
come on boys
[Applause]
the rule of two is something they've
never had to implement before
[Applause]
this band of a dozen officers came under
attack for picking off one single
protester
[Applause]
[Music]
so rather than kettling the group it was
a case of asking people to go home
and if they didn't arrest him
[Applause]
the images of people being arrested for
protesting won't sit well
with the dozens of tory back benchers
preparing to rebel
against the government's post lock down
tier system which sees tighter walls
than before lockdown this is how the uk
looked at that point in early november
very few places in the highest tier
three category
and this is the situation now almost the
entire country placed
in two and three one of the areas of
contention is the west midlands where
places with very different infection
rates have been put
under the same restrictions in coventry
there's nearly 200 cases per hundred
thousand
but in stratford-upon-avon it's nearly
half that
stratfor is the constituency of nadim
zahawi who's just been appointed to
oversee the vaccine deployment and hear
there's mixed feelings about being in
tier three
it seems to have blanketed everything so
obviously south warwickshire has been
locked in with northwestern it seems
a strange decision when you think again
the rate around here has been pretty low
consistently
you could keep on you know dissecting it
and cutting it up as much as you want
but i think at some point you've got to
draw a line and
i think everybody seems to uh i think
there's a will amongst people that
you know let's just get through this
none of it's fair is it we're in a
pandemic
viruses aren't fair either trying to
head off a backbench rebellion
cabinet office minister michael gove has
written in the times saying that unless
action to slow the spread of
coronaviruses taken
the nhs could be broken and hospitals
physically
overwhelmed the only way of breaking
transmission
is actually to keep people apart now
one can do this if one's got a very good
test trace and isolate system
unfortunately uh the current uk system
isn't fit for purpose isn't working well
so in the absence of that we have to
have this much
cruder blunter instrument of you know
regional wide restrictions
[Applause]
and while there's anger here at the
restrictions scientists advising the
government
fear that slight relaxation over
christmas will result in a rise in
coronavirus transmission
and that could bring even tougher rules
back in the new year
[Applause]
jason farrell sky news